Ciao ragazzi! benvenuti a una nuova puntata di vita buttata! Il tema di oggi è.. Scuola!
*Musica*
Pensavate che ce ne saremmo andati per sempre, invece eccoci qui all'interno degli studios del mio studios
Questa nuova serie sarà piena di sorprese, di ospiti stupendi, di novità pazzesche, oggi non succederà questo perché ci accontenteremo semplicemente di Matteo Bruno
Matteo! è un piacere! con una presentazione così.. Grazie sei sempre un amico.. Uno dei motivi per cui siamo molto contenti fare questo video
E' che in collaborazione con Actionaid, che si occupa di adozioni a distanza, e una delle cose alle quali non si pensa spesso è quella del diritto all'istruzione
Oggi noi parleremo di un mondo di roba assurda, molti bambini nel mondo non hanno la possibilità di fare i commenti che farete oggi
Però vi spiegherò tutto quanto alla fine del video con più calma
*Ciao gu! un giorno la mia sorella gemella che frequenta un'altra scuola* Adoro *Mi chiede disperata se posso sostituirla ad un interrogazione di inglese*
*In quanto gli scrutini sono alle porte e rischio il debito, insomma la mattina mi presento a scuola vestita e truccata come mia sorella
No vabbè... * E l'interrogazione va benissimo, e niente allo scoccare della campanella io me ne vado via
*E mia sorella che nel frattempo era stata tutto il tempo in bagno rientra in aula come se nulla fosse
E' GENIALE! CHE STIMA! Chiunque ha un gemello e ha fatto questa cosa ha la mia stima e la mia invidia più cocente
Parlando di scuola ti dico che.. ho una novità.. mi sono segnato all'università quindi il giochetto che vi chiedo di fare è
Indovinate qua sotto qual'è il percorso di studi che ho intrapreso, secondo te?
BIP*
Matteo avrebbe vinto! E' il vostro momento
*In primo superiore un mio compagno senza nessunissima ragione valida ha deciso di farsi riprendere mentre correva
*Contro un muro dell'aula e ci si schiantava sopra, il muro dell'aula che non aveva fatto niente di male fatto di cartongesso*
*E quindi quando ci si è schiantato contro ha fatto un buco con il piede quindi alla fine lo hanno coperto con un pannello di legno e non gli hanno fatto pagare niente
*Ciao Willwoosh, vi mando questo vocale da parte del mio ragazzo, a gennaio è andato con la classe in gita a Praga*
*E ha dimenticato un suo compagno di classe sull'autobus, erano stati in discoteca e quando sono tornati in albergo non si sono accorti*
*Che questo si era addormentato sul sedile*
*In una gita io e la mia amica mia amica andammo a litigare nella stanza di due compagni di classe insopportabili
*Poi le professoresse ci sgamarono, allora noi scappammo e ci nascondemmo nell'armadio, siamo rimaste chiuse nell'armadio per tipo un'ora*
*E sentivamo loro che parlavano male di noi, ed è stato molto bello poi quando siamo uscite dall'armadio*
Mi piace molto il fatto che l'inizio della storia sia.. "Stavamo andando in quella stanza per litigare" cioè oh ce l'hai 5 minuti? te devo sbroccà considera.. apposto
*Una cosa che facevo molto spesso a scuola, che quando c'era la lezione di diritto, mi mettevo in fondo all'aula e appena cominciava l'appello facevo il falco*
*Verso del falco fatto malissimo*
*Ad ogni nome..*
Poveri professori, ma perché poi tu pensi di essere nascosto, che nessuno sa che sei stato te, ma è palese che sei stato te
Fai un passo indietro, tu pensi di essere simpatico ed è per questo che lo fai, cioè tu lo fai perché in questo modo sei cool
Ma quel professore che ha fatto già vent'anni di carriera all'interno della scuola e dell'insegnamento quante aquile, quanti uccelli.. vabbè..
Quanti volatili ha sentito all'interno delle sue classi
Io non vorrei poter mettere le note, io vorrei poter dare punizioni corporali come nel medioevo.. cioè capisci, io pazienza zero
*Ciao Gu ciao ospite, era l'anno scorso all'orale di maturità, inizio a parlare tutto bene, dopo cinque minuti, colpo di scena..*
*Vomito l'anima davanti a tutti i professori, morale della favola.. sono uscita con cento e lode*
Abbiamo appena scoperto il metodo! A saperlo prima.. Bastava sbrattà! A saperlo prima, tu ti ricordi il tuo esame al liceo
Io mi ricordo benissimo che all'esame di terza media sono arrivato in ritardo.. ma di quanto? Tanto
Perché mi ricordo che mi hanno chiamato per dirmi "Oh tocca a te" E io stavo a casa, avevo letto male sul tabellone degli orari
Abbiamo ascoltato un po' di commenti direi a questo punto di prenderci un secondo di pausa con il segmento
*Segmento*
Allora Matteo.. preferiresti poter cambiare il futuro o il passato? con la sola forza del pensiero
Il passato.. però pensa che panico che crei, come ti muovi.. è un disastro, fai il delirio, pero è bello fai un po'  di caciara
Preferisci me o Claudio di Biagio?
Eh vabbè però ehmm assolutamente te.. guarda posso dirti.. assolutamente te, anche perché Claudio non c'è
Preferiresti ubriacarti e rivelare tutti i tuoi segreti o ubriacarti e rivelare tutti i segreti del tuo migliore amico?
Del mio migliore amico, senza dubbio, ma perchè hai degli scheletri nell'armadio?
Ho degli armadi divisi per stagione con gli scheletri, scheda primavera, scheda inverno, quello è il mio stile
Preferiresti porre fine alla fame nel mondo o tenere  assistenza sanitaria gratuita per ogni essere umano sulla terra
Pensa che Actionaid fa entrambe le cose, e al momento sta aiutando cinque milioni di persone nel mondo
Quindi era una domanda a trabocchetto, e volevo vedere cosa avresti cosa avresti scelto, ma come al solito pavido non sai prendere una decisione nella tua vita
E' finito il segmento grazie Matteo!
*Ciao Gu! e ciao Ospite, nel mio liceo c'era questa tradizione di vestirsi ogni giorno dell'ultima settimana di scuola di un tema diverso
*Tra cui c'era anche quello di vestirsi in pigiama, e feci in pigiama l'ultima interrogazione di chimica che non mi scorderò mai*
Stupendo! ma questo è un aneddoto meraviglioso, questa è una cosa stupenda da fare che tu fai l'ultima settimana nella quale ti vesti come ti pare
E secondo me dovrebbe essere una cosa che viene anzi implementata quotidianamente, proprio nel programma scolastico
Bisogna fare che almeno una settimana all'anno c'è questa cosa.. E' fichissimo, ma tu vuoi mettere invece di lanciare uova contro gli autobus
E pacchi di farina contro le vecchiette pare che ne so che nell'ultima settimana di scuola nella quale ti travesti
Ecco che sembra un qualcosa che spreca meno cibo e allo stesso tempo mi sembra un pochino più divertente
Tu hai mai fatto cose cosi a scuola? Io usavo fare questa cosa di mettere un po' di bianchetto sul banco e dargli fuoco
Perché il bianchetto è altamente infiammabile, avevi freddo? No no è proprio che era simpatico il momento dopo
Quando c'era questo odore di incendio chimico nella classe, che succede? Ha preso fuoco un'auto fuori dalla classe capito ?
Si vedeva una fiamma ad un certo punto *whoommm!* Una piccola fiamma, tipo un piccolissimo falò
Non si fa.. però io accendevo questa piccola fiamma, aspettavo quei pochi secondi affinché l'odore fosse giusto e poi si spenge
Tu hai criticato quello che faceva i versi dell'aquila, io vengo da una classe, lo dico onestamente che ha fatto tante tante cose
Molte di queste non posso dirvele.. Ah proprio.. Non posso dirvele ma.. un giorno non ci andava di fare la lezione
Abbiamo cercato di creare un diversivo.. abbiamo ribaltato i banchi quindi chi entrava aveva tutte le nostre nuche
E c'erano quelli li che volevano fare i fighi che stavano dritti poi c'eravamo io e una serie di miei amici che era questo.. Buongiorno prof!
Cercavi in qualche modo.. Impavido! Esatto! Quello che deve essere un po' nella regola ma mi ci rivedo molto
Io mai stato capito uno che doveva fare cose così, poi per carità potete anche se volete censurarmela però abbiamo avuto il lancio
*BIP*
Di un mio amico..
E che per fortuna aveva..
*BIP*
E avevamo un altro che non si lavava, però credo questa fosse la cosa più tranquilla di tutte
*Ciao Gu, allora io penso che la mia naturale propensione alla tristezza e alla malinconia sia in qualche modo da imputare alla mia maestra delle elementari
*E ti spiego perché poesia di natale, tutte le classi imparavano queste belle poesie tutte colorate, così gioiose sul natale
*Mi ricordo che un'anno mi ritrovai a recitare in piedi sulla sedia davanti ai miei parenti con fierezza questi versi di Ungaretti
*Non ho voglia di tuffarmi in un gomitolo di strade con tanta stanchezza sulle spalle, lasciatemi qui come una cosa posata e dimenticata* Oh madonna..
*Capisci?* Bellissimo.. Bellissimo, e ancora se lo ricorda, pensa.. E allora ha ragione che è un trauma eh
Avevo una professoressa molto particolare per un anno, di filosofia, che parlava con questo tono di voce.. Nooo, però
Si era comprata una cassa con un  microfono, lei stava con il microfono ad archetto, non ci credo! Ti giuro e quindi noi facevamo le lezioni di filosofia con questo ASMR
Non ci credo! Però fortissimo! Capito questo.. Ad un volume mostruoso, ma è un genio! Pazzesco, ma lei andava in giro anche a parlare con le persone
Tipo che ti metteva la cassa davanti e ti bisbigliava o poi tirava su? ALLORA CIAO COME STAI TUTTO APPOSTO?
Ciao sono Veronica in che modo posso aiutarti!
Siamo arrivati alla fine di questo video ragazzi, grazie mille Matteo, grazie mille a voi e grazie mille ad Actionaid che si occupa ve lo ricordo ancora
Da oltre trenta anni di adozione a distanza, noi vi abbiamo raccontato quelli che sono i nostri aneddoti legati alla scuola
Ma sappiate che milioni di bambini non hanno questa possibilità, e non solo non possono avere degli aneddoti divertenti da poter raccontare
Ma allo stesso tempo non hanno la possibilità di accedere a quegli strumenti che ti permettono di immaginare, sognare e avere un futuro diverso
l'adozione a distanza è uno strumento potentissimo per poter cambiare questa situazione, bastano nove euro al mese per cambiare la vita di un bambino
Io ho un aneddoto legato alla scuola di quando sono stato in africa e ho visto le scuole di questi bambini in Mozambico
Ho visto questa classe che stava sotto un albero, all'ombra di un albero e la maestra faceva la lezione su questa lavagna che era appesa ad un ramo
E io ho pensato ma che carino, che bel siparietto, in realtà la questione è che non avevano una classe fisica in cui stare, e lì arriva Actionaid
Perché può costruire una classe in cui i bambini possono fare lezione e comunque Actionaid non si occupa solo del lato fisico e materiale
Del costruire  le classi e i libri ma principalmente lavora sul dare il diritto all'istruzione, il diritto alla sanità e quindi rendere queste comunità indipendenti
Questa è la base.. Lo scorso video poi ha ricevuto da parte vostra una generosità enorme, vi prego cerchiamo di continuare a farlo
Perché veramente possiamo cambiare la vita delle persone, vi lascio il link in descrizione, adottiamo un bambino a distanza con Actionaid, DAJE!
E questo video è finito, è finito.. Ciaoo!
*Musica*